NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE
CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MR CLERK PLEASE CALL ROLL ACOSTA
[inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
ROOM [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAO [inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLEY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
PHONE [inaudible]
FRASER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
GRAY AND HARPER [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN GUCCI [inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
WE'VE US [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
WE SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBERS AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR TODAY'S INVOCATION.
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA [inaudible]
REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
BENEATH THE WORRIES WE MAY HAVE.
WHERE THE CONCERNS WE MAY CARRY
IN LIVING OUR WHILE SCHEDULED
LIVES?
DEEP DEEP WITHIN.
ALL HUMAN BEINGS WISH FOR A
HAPPY LIFE.
NO ONE WAKES UP IN THE MORNING
THINKING.
I HOPE I HAVE A MISERABLE DAY.
NO ONE WISHES FOR A DAY FILLED
WITH CONFLICT AND DISHARMONY.
WE ALL WISH FOR HARMONY AND
HAPPINESS.
OF HARMONY THAT ALLY LIMA WHO'S
EIGHTY SECOND BIRTHDAY IS
TOMORROW.
AND WAS THE SPECIAL GUEST HERE
IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WISELY SAID.
BECAUSE WE ALL SHARE THIS PLANET
EARTH.
WE HAVE TO LEARN TO LIVE IN
HARMONY AND PEACE WITH EACH
OTHER AND WITH NATURE.
THIS IS NOT JUST A DREAM.
BUT IN A SENSE CITY.
OF HAPPINESS THE DALI LAMA HAS
SAID.
EVERYONE SEEKS HAPPINESS AND JOY
UPON US.
BUT WE SEEK IT FROM THE OUTSIDE.
MOST PEOPLE NEVER PAID ATTENTION
TO THE ULTIMATE SOURCE OF A
HAPPY LIFE.
WHICH IS INSIDE.
THE ULTIMATE SOURCE OF HAPPINESS
IS NOT MONEY AND POWER.
BUT WARM HEARTED.
NOW MOVING DOWN WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU I INVITE YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
PLEASE JOINING US INCLUDING OUR
FLAG I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO THE
FLAG.
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. TO THE
REPUBLIC [inaudible] ONE NATION.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE FOURTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A CINEMATIC
TWELVE NOON THE OUTLOOK OF THE
MOST REMOTE AND WORRISOME
BECAUSE I CALDERON DOESN'T MISS
WALDRON SECONDS OF THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE.
IT'S WITH PRESENTATIONS OF THE
IS THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED HERE MOTIONS
[inaudible]
BUT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BONTA OBERNOLTE.
EDUARDO GARCIA WEBER AND MATHIS
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OBERNOLTE HE GARCIA
WEBER AND MATHIS IS GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT THEIR DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THEY CAN BENEFIT YOUR REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS PLEASE RETURN THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE SENATE AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN BLOOM.
AND ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN A.
B..
THIRTY TO SIXTY ONE LOW THE
CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
DODD FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM NUMBER. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT SP AYE ELEVEN THIRTEEN
MINING FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WE WILL FIRST MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA FOR HIS
VERY SPOKE.
A MEASURE SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
A GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S MY PLEASURE.
TO INTRODUCED TO YOU ALL SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN MENTIONED HERE TIME
AND TIME AGAIN.
SHE JUST REMINDED ME THAT THIS
IS HER THIRD TIME HERE.
HER THIRD TIME HERE SO.
I THIS IS THE ALAMAIN GARCIA
ALSO KNOWN AS ALLAH FROM
COACHELLA THINK YOU ARE PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME HER TO THE
ESTATE CAPITAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS AND THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS --
WITH ME TODAY IS MY YOUNGEST SON.
JEFFERSON LOCK MATHIS.
WHO WAS BORN AT TWO THIRTY SIX
A. M. ON DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE SAME MORNING NICE
FOREIGN OFFICE?
SO IF YOU GUYS WOULD PLEASE
WELCOME JEFFERSON [inaudible]
THEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THEY COMMITTED SPEAKER OF
MEMBERS I AM PROUD INTRODUCED MY
YOUNGEST SON TROY HE IS A
VALEDICTORIAN CANADA'S HIGH
SCHOOL IN BIG BURLY GOING INTO
HIS SENIOR YEAR.
WE'LL BE HEADING OFF TO COLLEGE
NEXT YEAR HAD DESPITE MY BEST
EFFORTS HE REFUSES TO RULE OUT
POLITICS AS A FUTURE CAREER
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING.
HIM TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND CONTINUING ON THE SAME THEME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YES GOOD MORNING MEMBERS AND I
TO RISE.
TO DO YOU SOME VERY SPECIAL
PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW MOST OF US KNOW THAT
JOB WE WORK VERY HARD IN THIS
BUILDING AND SOME OF YOU KNOW
THAT MY MOTIVATION COMES FROM MY
FATHER.
WHO DESPITE HAVING A VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES UNKNOWNS AND
NOT UNLIMITED EDUCATION?
KNEW THAT EVERY DAY WHEN HE WORK
LIFE WOULD BE BETTER FOR HIS
CHILDREN AND THAT WAS TRUE.
WE NOW WORK WITH THE SAME
CONCEPT IN ANDFEAR THAT
TOMORROW MAY NOT BE BETTER FOR
OUR CHILDREN.
THE MOB OF MOTIVATION IS MY
HEART WE THOUGHT.
THE TWO YOUNG MEN I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY. ONE BY TWENTY FIFTY WILL
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE OTHER WILL BE THE
CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME
COURT.
I GIVE YOU CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE.
BUT THERE GO CLEAN UP MY
GRANDSON OF SIX ANGELINO COULD
DO COULD COME TO A FOUR YEARS
OLD.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU SPEAKER OUR MEMBERS
HAVE SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY TODAY.
A WORD MAYOR BARBARA HALLADAY IS
HERE WITH FIVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
SOME OF WHOM ARE PARTICIPATING
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S JUSTICE ACADEMY --
TRADITIONALLY AM FORTUNATE TO
HAVE ONE OF THOSE STUDENTS --
WHO OP COULD NOT BE HERE IN
TURNING MY OFFICE AS WELL?
PLEASE GIVE A WARM ASSEMBLY
WELCOME TO MAYOR HALLIDAY AND
THE STUDENTS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE OUT
OF ORDER AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER. TO INTRODUCE HIS
ADJOURN IN MEMORY HE WAS GRANTED
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS AND GIVEN THE UTMOST
RESPECT ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
THANK YOU MATTHEW CREWMEMBERS.
AS WITH IMMENSE SADNESS THAT
TODAY I DURING MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENT FRIEND.
ROBERT ALLENBY LINE.
ROB PC PASSED AWAY NAIL GROWTH
ON JUNE TWENTIETH.
ROB IS AN AWARD WINNING
VIDEOLOGGER FOR AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY A GROUP
OF SACRAMENTO THE TENDENCY HIGH
SCHOOL AND SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
ROBIN JONES DAY JOB SHOOTING
VIDEO NEWS FOR FOX.
FORTY HE ALSO SHOT VIDEO FOR CBS
NFL GAMES [inaudible]
VERBAL.
FIFTY THE TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN MUNNERLYN AND
SUMMER OLYMPICS.
WE WON THREE EMMY AWARDS.
I CIVIL FOND MEMORIES OF ROB.
DURING MY TENURE THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SPOKESMAN --
IN THE LATE EIGHTIES AND EARLY
NINETIES AND TIMES A SPOKESMAN
AND OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE OUT THERE
ON CRIME SCENES FOR MANY MANY
HOURS INTERACTING WITH THE NEWS
MEDIA.
AND DOWN THE BECOME YOUR FAMILY
STILL OVER THE YEARS --
POINT OUT TO OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
I DEALT LA MISTER REALLY
UPSTANDING GUY.
KNOWS IT THEIR STATIONS BETWEEN
SOUTH SACRAMENTO A LOT GOES ON
DOWN THERE SO.
I GOT TO NEW ROB VERY WELL
REALLY ENJOYED HIM --
BOB IS SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING
WIFE KATIE [inaudible]
DAUGHTER BROOKE [inaudible]
SON BRADY.
SUBTLE ALMIGHTY COOL.
AND RAINY AND BROTHER BRIAN
BEELER AND ROB'S BROTHER TIM
RAINY WAS A FORMER MAYOR CITRUS
HEIGHTS AND COUNCIL MEMBER.
AND I KNEW HIM --
MANY TIMES DURING MY YEARS AS
THE ACCOUNTS IN ELK GROVE.
IS MEMBERS ARE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE LETTING STAND UP PLEASE --
MEMBERS RUN WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED PLEASE JOIN ME IN SENDING
OUR CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY.
PROCEEDED UPSTAIRS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR GRUBER BREAK PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DEATH TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST RETURN A MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING NOW TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM ONE OH SIX S. B. NINE NO
ONE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SO TO GO NINE A ONE BY SENATOR
DODD OTHERS AND ACT LIKE THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON
HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
OF THIS BILL.
S. B..
NINE OH ONE ADDRESSES WHILE FIRE
SAFETY FOR THE UTILITIES BY
ENSURING.
THAT THERE ARE SOUND POLICIES IN
PLACE FOR USE OF RE CLOSERS.
AND THE DE ENERGIZING OF LINES.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THIS BILL
OUTLINES THE MANY POLICIES ON
THE TABLE THIS YEAR TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES SURROUNDING.
THE INCREASING THREAT OF
WILDFIRES AND OTHERCATASTROPHIC
LOSSES WHICH INVOLVED OUR
ELECTRIC GRID.
WITH THE GOAL OF ENHANCING THE
SAFETY RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY OF THE GRID
PROTECTING RATEPAYERS AND
STABILIZING THE UTILITIES.
THIS WILL FORM THE FOUNDATION OF
A TWO HOUSE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK ON THE ITEM MISTER COOK
WAS OPEN THE ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY NO.
ONE MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE OF
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND JOINT RULES TWENTY
EIGHT TO A POINT ONE IT.
COMMITTEE ON S. B. NOT A ONE TO
PERMIT THE APPOINTMENT OF FIVE
CONFEREES.
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MOVES
TO SUSPEND A JOINT RULES MEMBERS
THIS REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE MEMBERS THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY KNOWS ZERO THE JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN S. B. NINE THIRTEEN MISTER
QUICKLY ST.
SO THE BILL NINE THIRTEEN BY
CENTER HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC WORKS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED DANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER WATCH HOW FAST I DO THIS
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL PROVIDE A
TIMELINE FOR THE AGREEMENT%
OUTLINED IN THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IVA.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE [inaudible]
ALL OPPOSED THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED.
THE ITEM IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. ONE S. B. NINE TO
ONE WE HAVE IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM NINETY SIX S. B..
ELEVEN NINETY TWO MR COURT
PLEASE READ.
SO THE BILL ELEVEN NINETY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER
MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THESE
ARE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS LATER
THAT.
DEFINITION OF NON DAIRY MILK.
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT GUIDELINES I ASK FOR
THE ADOPTION AND FOR THE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED THE ITEM IS THE AYE ITEM
IS BACK.
GUYS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THAT OBJECTION WE ARE
MOVING TO ITEM ONE TWELVE S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY TWO MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SO BILL TWELVE THIRTY TO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MANNER SPEAKER I
PRESENT S. B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO
THIS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADDING CHAPTER IN AMENDMENTS.
BILLS RECEIVE NO OPPOSITION HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
ITEM IS BACK ON FILE.
AN OUT OF PRINT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE BACK IN ORDER TO ITEM
SIXTY NINE AJ ARE.
FORTY FIVE THE CLERK PLEASE READ.
SO ME JOINT RESOLUTION FORTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER BUT SOARING
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE SIXTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE KOREAN WAR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND NOT
MEMBERS ARE TODAY I RISE UP TO
PRESENT OUR AJ ARE.
FORTY FIVE IN THE SUMMER
REMEMBER INSTALL OF GIVE BREAK
OUT OF THE KOREAN WAR. TO
ENCOURAGE.
OF SAI SAI IN THE ONGOING PEACE
TALKS RELATED THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
OUGHT TO CONTINUE.
A COMING TO THE TABLE WITH YA
SINCERE INTENTION OF ACHIEVING
PEACE IN THE REGION. SIXTY EIGHT
YEARS AGO ON JUNE TWENTY FIFTH
NINETEEN FIFTY COMMUNIST ON
NORTH KOREA KOREAN FORCES ARE
INVADED SOUTH KOREA.
THIS STARTED THE KOREAN WAR OF
WHICH LED TO DE OUT THAT'S OVER
360-005-0016 AMERICANS AND ON
YOUR THE ONE MILLION SOUTH
KOREANS.
BE AROUND UNSOLVED JUST WERE ARE
STILL EVER VISIBLE AS THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
CONTINUOUS OUGHT TO BE SPLIT UP.
THE WAY IT WAS SAW SINCE OUR
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE THIS SIDE
DECADE LONG CONFLICT.
HOUSE SO SPLIT UP FAMILIES.
AND THE CONTINUOUS AUTO HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THE PEOPLE
OF WILL COVER YEAH.
YET THE WITH THE RECENT MEETINGS
UP BETWEEN THE LEADERS OFF THE
UNITED STATES NORTH KOREA AND
THE SOUTH KOREA KOREAN PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORD.
HAVE BEEN NOT.
IS STILL THE WITH US NEW HOPE.
FOR THE OUR FUTURE PROSPECT OF A
PEACE ARE IN THIS REGION. FOR
THIS REASON SO I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME AND THE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A KOREAN AMERICANS SO
IN EXPRESSING A WILL HOLE. FOR
THE CONTINUED SUCCESS.
OF ALL FUTURE MEETING SO.
I ASKED OUT TO THE FIRST ROW BR
OPEN.
FOR COLE ALSO SAW HER FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
AND UP ON THIS SO IMPORTANT NOW
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SEEING THE NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK --
I AM SORRY I BEG YOUR PARDON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF AJ ARE FORTY FIVE TO
COMMEMORATE JUNE TWENTY FIFTH AS
THE SIXTY EIGHTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE ARMITAGE'S OF THE KOREAN WAR.
BOTH NATIONS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA AND THE REPUBLIC OF
KOREA HAVE SIMILARITIES.
SHARED RESPECT FOR THE VALUES OF
DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM AND A
STRONG LOVE OF INDEPENDENCE.
DECADES SINCE THE ARMY TO THIS
WAS SIGN MANY OTHER AREAS OF THE
WORLD HAVE GONE ON TO FIND
PEACEFUL SOLUTIONS TO THEIR DISK
DISAGREEMENTS.
YET THE KOREAS REMAIN DIVIDED BY
A DEMILITARIZED ZONE THAT
CONTAINS MORE DEADLY ALLY LAND
MINES THAT MANY NATIONS HAVE
POPULATIONS.
THE DIVISION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA SEPARATED MORE THAN
TEN MILLION KOREAN FAMILY
MEMBERS INCLUDING SOME WHO ARE
NOW CITIZENS OF THE UNITED
STATES.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS TIME TO CALL
FOR AN END TO DIVISION.
I CALL FOR A RENEWED COMMITMENT
TO FINDING A LASTING PEACE AND
AN END TO THE PAINFUL SEPARATION
OF FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES ALONG
FOREIGN BORDERS.
AND OUR OWN BORDER.
AND A TIME OF SENSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN FOREIGN
POWERS THE UNITED STATES SHOULD
REMAIN SOME SYMPATHETIC TO THE
KERN CERN'S OF SOUTH KOREAN
FAMILIES.
AND THEIR RELATIVES I HAVE AND
WHAT WILL ALWAYS SUPPORT ANY
SUBSTANTIAL EFFORTS FOR LASTING
PEACE FOR THE KOREAN PEOPLE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING AJ ARE [inaudible]
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU SEEING THAT
NO FURTHER REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE FOR COAUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CAR.
THIS ROTH MACARTHUR'S ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
MEMBERS THIS ROLES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE.
SORRY THIS REQUIRES A ROLL CALL
VOTE MATTER MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS LED DIRECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT AB EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SO MY REAL EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
INOCULATE THE PEACE OFFICERS.
SOME NEVER LACKEY ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THINK OF THE OPERAS DUTY TO
PRESENT AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
WHICH IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WILL HELP
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE BETTER
FULFILL ITS ROLE LICENSING
CANNABIS CULTIVATION.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WOULD
GIVE CDFA INVESTIGATORS NON
PEACE OFFICER STATUS.
THIS BILL IMPROVEMENT FORCED MET
BY CDFA BY ALLOWING THEIR
INVESTIGATORS TO PURSUE SEARCH
WARRANTS --
AND INVESTIGATIONS FOR LICENSEES
SUSPECTED OF VIOLATING CRIMINAL
LAWS BY DIVERTING PRODUCTS TO
THE ILLICIT MARKET.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT TO AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES BY SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSED.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ALL OTHER ITEMS WILL BE PASSING
RETAINED.
WE ARE MOVING BACK NOW TO MISTER
BONTA FOR HIS GUEST INTRODUCTION.
MR BODY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
MISTER MULLINS DUST.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M HONORED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE TWO
SPECIAL GUESTS FROM THE BAY AREA
TODAY JOINING US ON THE FLOOR.
ARE TEN SAYING RAGDOLL PRESIDENT
OF THE TIBETAN ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND PAST
PRESIDENT CAL SUN JUNE DAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR VISIT US
VISITING US HERE AND SACRAMENTO
IT'S OUR PRIVILEGE. TO HOST YOU
A MAP OF THE SPEAKER AND ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE.
ASSEMBLY.
THE BAY AREA IS HOME THE FOURTH
LARGEST TIBETAN COMMUNITY IN
NORTH AMERICA BEHIND NEW YORK
TORONTO AND MINNEAPOLIS AND MANY
TIBETAN AMERICANS ARE ESPECIALLY
PROUD TO CALL ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA.
AND SOLANO COUNTY IS HOME.
THEY ARE PART OF THE FABRIC THAT
HAS MADE THESE COMMUNITY
STRONGER AND MORE VIBRANT.
IN SO MANY WAYS THE ASSOCIATION
I WILL NOTE HAS DONE AN
ADMIRABLE JOB PROVIDING SERVICES
TO THE TO THE TIBETAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
FROM AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS TO
LANGUAGE CLASSESTO SPECIAL ART
EXHIBITS.
KANSEN AND HIS TEAM OF IT RICH
DARK COMMUNITIES WITH TIBET'S
RICH CULTURAL HERITAGE AND
TRADITIONS THANK YOU AGAIN TO
THE TIBETAN ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THAT
YOU DO.
I CAN'T THINK OF A MORE
APPROPRIATE.
TIME TO HONOR YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU AND WE ARE MOVING TO
SECOND READING.
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE ELEVEN TWENTY FIVE
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE MINUTES
959-147-7830 THREE WITH THE
MINUTES TEN SEVENTY SIX WOMEN
IT'S A NINETY FOUR THE MINUTES.
TWELVE FORTY SIX FIFTEEN TEN
TOTAL THREE THIRTY THREE FORTY
THREE OF THE MEMBERS TO TWENTY
SEVEN OF THE MEMBERS SEVEN
TWENTY WITH A MINUTES. NINE
THIRTY THREE WITH THE MARRIAGE
TO NINETEEN WITH A MEMBERS
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
MINUTES THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE OF
THE MINUTES TO TWENTY FOUR
MINUTES.
NOT BEFORE THE MEMBERS FORTY
FIFTY THREE OF THE MEMBERS NE
SEVENTY FOUR OVER THE MINUTES
ELEVEN TWENTY NINE OF THE
MINUTES TWELVE FORTY FOR THE
MEMBERS 829-691-01210 SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN AWAIT ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN AND SENATE BILL SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOVING OUT OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
HAS ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY BY SENATOR
BATES AN ACCOLADE A REAL ESTATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
VOTE.
MR CLARKE MAKE CLOTHES A ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES I SUCCEED NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
WE WILL DEFER THE READING UNTIL
ADJOURNMENT.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER PURSUANT
TO JOINT RULE FIFTY ONE BE.
TO I MOVE THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED FOR SUMMER RECESS
UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND CONSENT
FOR THE SENATE TO DO THE SAME
[inaudible]
WITHOUT ASECONDED BY MISTER
WALDRON WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS JULY SIXTH TO AUGUST
THIRD RECESS AUGUST SIX FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSION RETAIN ALL MOTION
CHUBBY CONTINUED PURSUANT TO THE
MOTION MADE EARLIER BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON THIS HOUSE IMAGE
OF SAM'S ADJOURNED FOR THE
SUMMER RECESS UNTIL MONDAY
AUGUST SIX AT ONE PM
.
MOVING BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SO THE CURRENT RESOLUTION.
TO SEVENTY AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SO THE BILL FIVE TWENTY TWO
AYE AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS YOUR
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY SIX AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SUITABLE
NINE TWENTY AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO CID [inaudible] TO
EMERGENCY.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
ZERO NINE SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SUITABLE TENANT ó
THREE AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO CYNICAL
TEN FORTY TWO AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TEN NINETY
EIGHT I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE BILL.
ELEVEN THIRTEEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SO THE BILL OF FIFTY
THREE AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS HE'S
GONNA BILL ELEVEN NINETY NINE
AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO CID AGO
TWELVE WHAT WE AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY
NINE HIGH. SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE BILL TWELVE EIGHTY AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO CYNICAL
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE BILL
THROUGH TWO HUNDRED AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ZERO FIFTEEN OH
SIX AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE BILL THREE TO NO ONE AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NOCERA.
CITY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SIX AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO CYNICALFOR NINETY FIVE
WITH URGENCY AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO INCIDENT
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
TWO I SIXTY EIGHT NO